[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys pete here today i've got an
update on the sixth season of the
expanse yesterday i saw an article that
seems to confirm a rumor that had been
going around about the expanse's final
season being shorter and possibly as
short as only six episodes getting less
expanse is never good news as far as i'm
concerned but i thought i'd try to look
at this and see if it makes sense there
will be some slight spoilers here about
the structure of the sixth book in the
series babylon's ashes but i won't be
giving away anything that might spoil
what's going to happen especially how it
might end with that out of the way let's
get started
on september 6 2021 the midgard times
posted an article titled the expanse
season 6. end is coming and it could be
shorter than we expect the article makes
a few key assertions first that the
final season is supposed to drop in
december although that's not finalized
then it's possible that it might be
moved to january next we know the show
has been in post-production since june
and the article claims that they can
confirm that's going to end on november
26th which would mean the show would be
done and could premiere anytime after
that and finally that they have reports
that the season will only be made up of
six episodes which would make it the
shortest expanse season by far i guess
the first question to ask is any of this
credible by name the midgard times
definitely doesn't carry the weight of a
publication like deadline or hollywood
reporter might but at the same time this
is a weirdly specific kind of breaking
news article from a website that might
be smaller but isn't really a click-bait
outlet
to me it sounds like they have contact
with someone who works on visual effects
for the show and i can't say for sure if
the expanse does this but it is a thing
that some visual effects work does get
outsourced but beyond that they make a
pretty good argument based on the number
of shooting days on season 6. it's been
reported elsewhere that they filmed from
january 27th through may 7th which is a
total of 98 days to quote the article if
the series is going to have 10 episodes
50 minutes to 1 hour each that means
each episode with all the covered
regulations have to take only 9.8 days
to complete also the cast and crew would
have worked without taking a break now
let's compare that to the previous
season which took five months
approximately 150 days including
holidays and weekends to complete the
production that means 15 days or two
weeks on each episode they concluded
based on that calculation that their
source is credible and saying that
there's probably only gonna be six
episodes they go on to say that they
think that the maximum you could shoot
in that time period would be seven or
eight episodes and they don't think it's
likely considering that a sci-fi series
has so much post-production work i'll
have to default to one thing being a
fact and that is that it's indisputable
that they filmed season six in
significantly less days than they spent
on the previous seasons and with the
pandemic those restrictions would
probably slow production if anything so
with a possible inside source and other
reports from people saying that they've
heard similar things plus a logical
breakdown of the time spent shooting a
six-episode final season does seem
possible
my knee-jerk reaction was to feel kind
of crushed i want more not less
especially since this is the last season
that we know for sure is being made i
saw a lot of comparisons to the final
season of game of thrones being thrown
around which is still the go-to example
of not ending things in a satisfying way
the question i wanted to look at in this
video is does a short season mean that
we can expect to be disappointed by the
ending of our beloved expanse series and
to that i gotta say no even coming from
the perspective of not loving to hear
this and still hoping that it might not
be accurate the game of thrones
comparisons don't really fit with the
expanse there is already an ending to
the sixth book which is what they're
adapting here and it came out years ago
it was written by the authors who also
write for and produce the television
show and they've understood where
they're taking this story from the
beginning so when you look at that it's
just night and day compared to a show
that passed this source material halfway
through and was being adapted by someone
else who was working towards a list of
bullet points on how it would end what's
funny is i did notice at the end of
season 5 when they were doing their
interviews they didn't confirm how many
episodes the final season would have
they were actually kind of elusive about
it and at the time of course i was
hoping that that meant that it could be
longer and i did go back and look at
those earlier today and it's clear they
didn't want to answer that question
which means they could have known that
it was going to be shorter or it might
be and they didn't want to get that out
there because people do tend to make
that got comparison
in my recent future of the expanse video
i talked about the potential release
date for season 6 and looked at the
post-production times for the previous
seasons that led me to suspect that the
show would probably come out later in
the winter or early spring rather than
december and if it really is coming out
at the end of the year like it usually
does then that would almost certainly
mean less episodes but where this really
started to sink in was when i started
thinking about where things were left at
the end of season 5 and what parts of
the story had already been moved forward
and i just want to throw it out there
that ever since it was confirmed that
season six would only be an adaptation
of babylon's ashes with none of the
story from the final trilogy being
brought in people have asked a question
about how could they stretch what
happens in that book out for the length
of a 10 episode season i wasn't one of
those people prior to season 5 coming
out but now it does seem a little more
likely primarily because of drummer's
story and the fact that she broke with
marco and the free navy in the finale a
lot of the sixth book deals with the
character michio paw she's a point of
view character who's working with and
eventually breaks from marco and the
free navy and a big turning point
halfway through michio is one of the
characters that was absorbed into show
drummer's story in season 3 and they
loosely did the same thing in season 5.
also philip already found out that naomi
survived her hard vacuum transit to the
chatsumoka and fred johnson is already
dead that's a pretty big chunk of the
setup and three plot points they've
already moved through towards the ending
and that does have an effect
some other things to think about with
less episodes that could mean that
they're spending more on each of them
and there are some things that could be
pretty impressive to see on screen if
they wanted to go really big on some
episodes they could actually streamline
some of the story to get there and not
lose much the runtime could also be a
little longer but at some point it
wouldn't make sense for them to be much
longer considering the shooting time i
guess the one immediately gratifying
thing would be that the show might
arrive sooner and there would probably
be an announcement and even a trailer
next month
i'm interested to hear what you think
about a six-episode run if you've read
the books i think it could probably work
and it might even be optimal it doesn't
mean that i have to like it but overall
what's most important is that they
deliver an ending that feels complete
for what they're trying to say i suppose
in that light since i don't have a good
reason to think that they would be under
constraints and they wouldn't be able to
make a full season that we can trust
that if it turns out to be shorter then
that's what they thought would work best
the last thing to consider is that
they've already done this once they
condensed the third book down to seven
episodes at the end of season three and
in my mind that's a more complicated
story to tell they had to do that
without moving significant events up in
the timeline because of the ring gate so
if you really enjoyed the pace of the
second half of season 3 compared to the
first two and a half seasons you might
be in luck to get to wrapping this video
up i guess a lot of fans myself included
were hoping that we might see the
adaptation of strange dogs which is a
novella that happens in laconia about
the same time as the events of babylon's
ashes a shorter season might mean that's
not going to happen but that was never
confirmed and it's still pretty hard to
say how they'll leave things like i've
said in previous videos there is a
definitive ending to what's going on now
in book six as you might guess
considering that there's another trilogy
that follows that it definitely doesn't
answer all the questions and that's why
universally pretty much everyone wants
to see them figure out a way to adapt
the rest as far as this i think it's a
good place to leave it please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already i
wanted to take a second to say thanks to
the people who sent me tips from my last
video that's extremely generous and i
really appreciate it thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon